50 years ago in a lightning six-day war
Israel captured East Jerusalem West Bank
and Gaza the Israelis saw it as
liberation the Palestinians as the start
of occupation now conflict zone is in
the West Bank in Israel to record a
special series of interviews looking
back over the last 50 years my guest
here in the West Bank city of Ramallah
is Nubble shaft a former Palestinian
foreign minister advisor to the
president and peace negotiator why after
so long have the Palestinians achieved
so little
[Music]
that'd be shot welcome to conflict zone
but happy to media a lot of Palestinians
quoted in the media and look back at the
67 war and described the years since
then as a half century of humiliation
but a lot of it was self humiliation
wasn't it Palestinian disunity human
rights abuses corruption violence you're
going to tell me it's all Israel's fault
but it wasn't was it
when you can't really hit the the
murderer you you put the blame on the
murdered that's typically you have to
take some responsibility for the
violence the corruption the human rights
abuses inside the Palestinian
territories don't you because there are
problems we're human and even when we
are under occupation even when we are
with so many agony is caused by that
occupation we have our own mistakes but
the major problem is there but the
Palestinian people lay them at your door
we have the latest Palestinian polls
blame for the leadership only 25 percent
said the leadership is doing its best
41 percent said its role was inadequate
and 32 percent called it negligent so
it's time for you to go isn't it I think
this is much better than I thought
really they of course do you please buy
these reserved not not pleased at all
where they want you and say you're in
our it is normal when you fail to get
that settler occupation of your chest
when you fail to free your people when
you fail to develop to do to give them
independence way one way when you say
say it is not our failure they say the
question has to do with straight balance
of power the Israelis are 40 times our
per capita income they have the
fourth-largest air air force in the
world they are an atomic country they
get all the support from the United
States and therefore they beat us we
write whether it remains that you've let
your people down you've let your peace
you don't hold elections anymore
apart for a few local ones but despite
the basic requirement in the Palestinian
basic law what on earth makes you think
you're still legitimate as leaders
that's not the issue you can see is no
no no the issue is they want you to go
and you say your day enough of the
results of this session if you really
want to talk about the separation yes I
think this has been our major failure or
inability to end the division between
Gaza and West one between Hamas and the
rest of the organization it was this
that really took away our ability to
continue our elective democracy we were
very proud of our elective democracy we
had full presidential and legislative
elections less than a year after we we
tell you as a president who is already
12 years into what was supposed to be a
four-year term yes but you know what
that's got nothing to do me but you know
what I did it's not nothing to do with
you I cannot hold a democracy under this
unity otherwise you consecrate the
division if we were to hold elections in
the West Bank only which is the only way
we can do it if Hamas rejects national
elections and Hamas did and if we will
do that yes we will have more democracy
in the West Bank but we do not represent
Palestine we then will be democratically
representing the West Bank alone this is
actually a rather serious you want why
is it that you and all the other
Palestinian factions are unable to put
aside your selfish factional interest
and work for the Palestinian people as a
whole you've had more bust-ups and more
reconciliations than a Hollywood
marriage haven't you yes I like your
style anyway but you know it's a bit
more serious than that isn't it now to
be more serious you really have to get
to the real issue there are issues in
which we are responsible no doubt if I
tell you we are Metro specific not
responsible that's not serious
your people expect better don't they the
daily they should expect they expect
that they should expect that a dancers
want able Mazen
to go they want him to resolve this is
great that means he has two-thirds and
one-third wanted to go that no 2/3 2/3
want him to go 2/3 800 got 80% why you
cling on God without
the question you need to have election
in all of Palestine you cannot have
election in the West Bank
having election the West Bank is worse
than delaying the Masterson excuse it is
not an excuse it is a you had like five
years ago you have we have elections
when we could do them in Gaza and the
West Bank then we have election punches
there are better people and there are
better people standing in the wings but
there are young as younger people
certainly standing in the wings are
there they should be there we should
have a new generation ruling Palestine
but that has to be done in a way that
leaves it open the door is left open to
unity we have to go to unity if we have
failed really in anything it's in in our
ability to defeat all the environmental
pressures in order to make unity because
making unity will regain democracy this
is issue it isn't that the little hope
on the horizon of you doing that is
there there's no hope whatsoever of you
two don't you ever mention that word
hope because without hope the
Palestinian would have vanished long
time ago hope is the the fuel that keeps
the Palestinians alive so hope doesn't
go away it's a question of finding a new
way of doing it if you're saying
something else let's let's talk about
violence because over the last 50 years
the violence of the Palestinian movement
has so colored international opinion
towards you and your fate by by the
1970s the Palestinian movement became
known for shocking acts of random
violence against civilians
not just in the Middle East but around
the world we got used to seeing your
masked gunmen shooting civilians
hijacking planes didn't do you any good
did it this kind of violence you know
when you are when you are facing the
violence of one of the most violent
occupations which is not really like the
civilized British occupation in which
the British government occupied India
just to enslave the Indians and get
money and wealth out of India but never
thought of throwing out the Indians and
bending the British people to take over
this the Dhiraj in India so this is the
Frenchy organizations like
Abu Nidal for instance that went around
killer I'm not excusing anything but I
am only telling you that when you face a
settlers Zionist occupation that is
determined to get you out and take your
place and they are already thrown out
particularly my television is it some
kind of justification you have got a
ghetto and shooting civilians is
everywhere around the world no not just
because of the children we don't do
children you mean whenever you did you
did you did some of us hijack planes and
we did our best to stop that and we did
their objective was not to kill anybody
their objective was to demonstrate to
the world the agony they feel but we did
not like it don't discuss we generally
do serenity of your money and of your
memory you have to also remember the
violence that Israelis have done you've
got to remember Sabra and Shatila you've
got to remember bury a scene you've got
to remember those those allies late will
come from the road job he'll remember
and when an industry when I make your
memory about some of the things that you
did in 1974 two of your hardline
factions raided northern Israel killing
43 civilians and children at a school in
my lot and a block of flats in Kiryat
Shmona you remembers yes I do and the
fact is that and we condemned it and we
stood against it and we in fact took all
the measures to make something else like
that happen we stopped it that I took
that I always I which is the major
living organization of of a pillow never
tried to violate the rules of the
International legality of struggle and
resistance against the occupation but
you had all these kinds of groups that
you were quite happy for them to go off
and sure people left right we were not
happy so hijack things we were not happy
to hijack anything we went into armed
struggle against the Israelis we shot
back at the Israelis every time they
attacked us we shot back at the Israeli
Armed Forces whenever there was a report
even we were you know we were in a
watershed let's talk about the attitude
your President Abbas has said recent
repeatedly that he renounced violence
and embrace security cooperation with
Israel okay much last year he says I
will not enter a violent struggle I will
not ruin my people my [ __ ]
respect at all I will never permit
violent struggle against Israel all
right okay but you dr. Shah are quite
happy for the violence to continue
aren't you you told you told Palestinian
elder TV earlier this month but you
never thought there was a problem with
engaging in armed struggle at the same
time as engaging in political and
diplomatic efforts didn't you in the
support of your cause the Palestinians
you said had an indisputable right to
take part in armed struggle here we are
sitting in the president's office two
radically different views one from you
the advisor and one from him the hold on
let me answer that because that's
exactly what exactly what Netanyahu did
to Abu Mazen inciting mr. Trump about
him he fabricated a video in which Abu
Mazen starts by saying I
incite against Israel so they say I
didn't fabricate any videos and you have
a brigade in the explanation I am I'm
talking about two different errors the
error of of armed struggle and their of
peaceful uses Islam and I said in the
error of armed struggle we had the right
under international law to fight back
our enemy who never came into Palestine
by negotiation they occupied Palestine
by war and that gives us and you don't
think we're giving the green light
now the other people to go are not at
all because Abu Mazen himself was part
of the unstable before we signed the
Oslo dream to condemn the stabbing I
don't understand sometimes he consent is
my knees I'm asking you is there
anything that he condemned that you
think of it I don't hear and then I
excuse the difference you see no no the
difference is you're also not treating
one on our side or signal will speak
with one voice because if we didn't
speak with one voice we will be found
out by but by the social media if we
don't speak by the White House so you
will see us on Twitter saying two
different things we will see us on
Facebook I'm logging you to say the same
thing
condemn the stabbings that has taken
place of Israeli civilians with them
that we did you I you won't do it when
did we decide to do count
wait wait wait and you can do it mr.
Netanyahu invitations ago inaugurated a
hospital
mr. Netanyahu and inviting you to
condemn what you say you do condemn
which is violence against this I come
but I do I I condemn violence against
civilians
I have condemned it even when we
engaging in in an armed struggle and
struggle is should only according to the
national law be addressed to the
occupying forces and not civilians so I
I condemn any violence against civilians
whether it is today or 100 years ago
that has not changed and that's why you
want to show me where you authorize
payments for terrorists isn't it this is
the big thing that they throw at you
there the international community object
this is the racist claim you are being a
racist when you raise that issue because
you cannot be racist enough to tell me
that 1 million Palestinians are
terrorists because they have all been
through this rail jail in 50 years 1
million Palestinians were in Israeli
jails where they are all terrorists when
I negotiated the Gaza Jellico agreement
with the Israelis there was 15,600 and
Israeli jails
this rain is accepted to release all of
them with the exception of 229 but
here's what here's what the
international community about yourself
international community calls hypocrisy
you promise security cooperation to
Israel to prevent attacks and then you
pay the attackers that violate that
problem we don't pay the attackers we
pay the family of people in Israeli
jails the Israeli government pays the
family of criminals who are in Israeli
jails well they buy your version the UN
announced in May that it stopped
supporting a Palestinian community
center in the West Bank because it was
named after a woman who took part in a
1978 terror attack the UN
secretary-general is a mild man is
Antonio Guterres that the glorification
of terrorism all the perpetrators that
heinous terrorist act is unacceptable
under any circumstance that you see
really the racist bias here as I was
really UN not from everybody reeling
from everybody everybody is erased not
everybody is there a sister all the time
but some good people can form your
international donors our radius is a
friend the parrot is a socialist but
is a progressive man he's condemned he
he can be in fact induced by the
Israelis or others to saving the totally
contradicted position in life why so he
just doesn't understand he's clueless is
he he just doesn't like only those who
understand are the Israelis and their
people these are the only people
understand Donald Trump when he was
recently here made it clear in public
standing next to President Abbas peace
can never take root in an environment
where violence is tolerated funded or
rewards exactly how do you understand
don't you I hardly I understand it with
my fingers ago he didn't down and I
mentioned Palestinian state or
Palestinian self-determination see
that's the price you pay he didn't know
anything oh no he didn't mention
anything he didn't say why he did hear
it is not mentioned moving the American
Embassy to Jerusalem he didn't mention
stopping settlements he didn't think she
didn't get anything out of the who did
indignation the unification of Jerusalem
area to get anything out of the visit
nobody got that you got forty five
already got anything we fried business
that visit you've got 45 minutes of his
valuable time why because in his words
violence is tolerated funded and
rewarded by by the Palestinians that's
what he didn't say that the Israelis
conduct violence daily that will be
talked about the Israelis destroying
Palestinian homes and building colonial
settlements instead but your
international donors dr. shelter getting
fed up by another violent are getting
fed up with this line of you know Prime
Minister confirmed in January that
foreign financial support to the
Palestinian budget it's about half the
forecast level Saudi Arabia stop making
regular contributions in April last year
the EU and the US have also reduced
direct budget support so so the world's
getting fed up with you shut up with
this line they're not accepting it from
you are they ah okay
you want that stood they what they want
you want them to be fed up with us and
to express that in not giving us enough
money or is the problem the money we
give to the prisoners families I mean I
don't know what premonitory well is it
not at all
regarding the funded no no that does not
employ is it the corruptions nothing or
is it the corruption
wanted to do with the reason what is it
this is it is their problems they are
facing problems they are financing
fights in Syria and Iraq and Yemen they
are having problems because the price of
oil have dropped down there are many
problems in the world why they are a
world are not giving us as much money as
they have promised they would they are
giving money but now they are preferring
to fund specific elements Roger the
Hasidic development project in America
I have no fear with you I mean something
why they gave basically they gave to the
United States and that is a political
decision that is not the humanitarian
decision it's a political decision and
we understand maybe four hundred million
billion dollars that were given to mr.
Trump was not really humanitarian was
not because they believed in the Justice
of his call this was a political issue
and we understand dr. Sharklets let's
talk about talks you personally along
with Yasser Arafat Mahmoud Abbas range
of Palestinian officials you spent years
negotiating with Israel with the US the
Europeans you weren't involved I think
you said in the famous Oslo talks that
saw an agreement signed in 1994 but you
saw it as did at Yasser Arafat is a new
beginning he said it would complete the
March at peace guarantee the legitimate
rights of the Palestinian people and
realize justice it didn't do any of
those things today was the agreement was
oversold wasn't it no the Israelis never
committed themselves to it and the
Americans never put any pressure to make
them commit themselves to this was an
agreement signed in the White House I
was there this was like an agreement
sound of mr. Rubin the moment an Israeli
extremists violent terrorists killed it
is Haq Rabine in Tel Aviv singing for
peace and mr. Netanyahu came and took
over also died Israelis don't diplomat
anything in Oslo today but any but the
light and hugely respected Palestinian
academic Edward Saeed was scathing about
Oslo wasn't he hold it
a Palestinian surrender a Palestinian
Versailles he said what made it worse
was that for at least the previous 15
years the PLO could have negotiated a
much better
arrangement no sympathy with that view I
read so again the Palestinians live it I
resurrect other side you're angry when
they's raise it with the Palestinians
reject resist you're angry again when
the pendulum when my cell opinions go to
peace one day I met with the Palestinian
sign an agreement with Israel you are
critical for this Raley's bond agreement
was all for me I'm not I'm asking you
question Edward
Sayid said to the advocates of this
peace document who claimed they had no
alternative the correct way of phrasing
it was that we had no alternative
because we either lost or threw away a
lot of others leaving only this one a
quarter of a century a quarter of a
century of negotiations and at the end
of it all you had to show was an
acknowledgment that the PLO represented
the Palestinian that was it that it
wasn't much was it that's not the issue
at all well that's what is the issue he
what he saw really was what what he saw
was a different expectation than the
expectation made by our leadership he
expected any interim agreement never to
become a permanent agreement and that
the Israelis are going to use the
interim nests in order to take the land
and water which they did and I think he
was wise and he saw it I'm a Hamas saw
this but he thought we could overcome it
he thought that with the international
support for the peace process the
support of President Clinton and and all
of that and the presence of mr. Rubin
might make it bitter you built in 1994
you created a Palestinian Authority with
one of the largest security budgets in
percentage terms of any state in the
world roughly roughly a third of your
four billion dollar budget is goes on
policing doesn't it that's more than
four health what a generation the reason
was to protect our ability to continue
implementing that agreement the reason
is that you wanted to turn this into a
police state no it is not because we you
have we did not have what we wanted was
to implement our part of the agreement
namely our part of agreement was
security that the Israelis used security
as their excuse for not
been back the Palestinians the land or
the rights we're just torturing your
detainees come into your idea of
creating security because by the end of
October last year the Independent
Commission for Human Rights in Palestine
had received a hundred and fifty
complaints of torture and ill-treatment
by Palestinian Authority security forces
why how does that come in and this goes
on and on yes this doesn't go on and on
if it does not and I've been asking the
question of Palestine English is like
you for the last 20 35 in the first 60
in the first years until 2006 we were in
Gaza and we were in a unity and we
brought in the Red Cross which is really
not its duty that course usually should
be looking at what the Israelis do as of
you're telling me your security people
are not torturing detainees because they
are and you know they they I know this
and they've been doing it for decades
yes but you know this but this why is it
too much for you to stop torturing
civilians engaged
we're peacefully exercising their right
and well whether you believe it off to
jail and when a US does and it's still
closed or there is no in various torture
in America they'd ever see remind
America you're not responsible for
America you are an you are responsible
to confirm and to look at the the panel
I talked to their no I'm joking I'm
talking to you about what you do I'm
talking to them when you're not
interfere again are you that this is not
really fair the hour why you're not
responsible no no because the Americans
made you in other countries do and very
limited torture I simply challenge you
if you say a hundred cases over 50 years
there is a difference between that and
what these days are doing and what you
know and done along the line of Israelis
are doing invent a basic question and
one thing is not allowed in our in our
Constitution that you do it can you
answer me this question at what point in
the life of this Palestinian Authority
are you going to start bothering about
human rights what for at what point in
our discussion are you going to talk
about colonial settlement in what point
in our discussion you are going to ask
me about the atrocities the Israeli
government they're talking quite a bit
that's why you found there quite a bit
I didn't we
even talked yet about settlements and
colonial settlements except as a
principle what destroy gives you that
what you do I know and you decide to
talk about what you want to the question
is there is a big size of destruction of
the peace process caused by the colonial
settlement program and a very tiny part
that you are exaggerating and they could
look like it is the problem the problem
is settler occupation of this land and
the decision by the Israeli government
never to give back never to go into a
two-state solution never to allow us to
regain half of Jerusalem never to to
give us the freedom and a choice to be
really free and democratic country we
are a country under fully occupation and
their full colonial grabbing of water
and and and and land and yes that the
river doesn't really interest you all on
what your interest in have few cases of
atrocities that I condemn if the police
has has committed them this is not a
government policy this is not a
commitment by our government this is not
a political act we talked earlier about
hope and you said Palestinians should
never give up hope o'clock last October
you were quoted by the Arab weekly as
saying the peace process with Israel
should be declared dead and Palestinians
should wake up from their peace dreams
what did you mean by that peace process
that Oslo thing that piece of poetry
that ever side rights turned out to be
right Oslo is dead and in fact mr.
turkey screaming God mr. stump is not
looking to revive Oslo he's thinking of
a new deal the Europeans in Paris were
not looking at Oslo they were looking
about a permanent deal Oslo is dead
the Israelis killed it the Israelis
killed it with with colonial settlement
killed it with control of our lives
killed it with with all the the actions
they did in order to take out of our
hands
the whole of the West Bank and including
Jerusalem that's what killed gospel so
Oslo is and did not die naturally Oslo
was killed by the Israelis
you can ask Israelis in the street is
the street any are we really going to
stop building certain
and taking away that of course not if
you say it's mr. Nathaniel really
interested in the two-state solution of
course not
so what killed Oslo is that not
criticism of our human rights behavior
there are countries who deserve much
more criticism about their human rights
being another chef has been good to have
you on the program
thank you
[Music]
it would be
[Music]
you
[Music]